like I said these are the kinds of
things which because they're so
important they come up again and again
and again you really want to have them
in your back pocket like you don't want
to have to think to get these now i am
against memorizing things for the sake
of memorizing things like that's one of
the quickest ways you could be like I
don't know what any of this means I just
blurted by rote and that's how I can say
it right you do want to understand
what's going on but memorizing can be
really useful right just like if I'm um
if any of you learn to drive okay you're
going to memorize like where your gear
is and how you move it up and down and
how many spots me because you don't want
to be like oh I've got a reverse hold on
on a pond is it ok right I'll find out
you can't take your eyes off the road
can't take your hand off the steering
wheel you want to have those things just
in here not having to think about them
consciously and it's a similar kind of
thing for this right now to get these to
get these side verde kind of is the
basic most important one that you
memorize because you get the rest of
them or less out of that one who
remembers the first fraction surges
simplest one it's a half very good okay
now you may recall we construct the
triangle out of this it looks like this
right angle if I put that 30 degrees in
the corner sign of course is which ratio
is it which sides opposite on hypotenuse
so here's the opposite and he is the
hypotenuse right you remember there's
the 1 over 2 okay and then from
Pythagoras we're showing that last side
in there is root 3 which will give you
the next ratio close 30 off the diagram
and Jason on hypotenuse right route 3 on
2 ok once you reach 45 degrees you need
that other triangle right if I've got
the right angle again and 45 what does
that mean up in the top corner for that
angle also 45 so this is our I'm so
sceles right angle triangle we got here
right so if i call these sides equal 1
and 1 that means the hypotenuse is going
to be from Pythagoras route to you might
remember that number ok so therefore
cost 45 adjacent and hypotenuse it's one
on route
to 1060 we can return to our first
triangle for that one what ratio of
science is tan what r you is it so I
taught opposite on adjacent there's 60
up there right so you've got to get
opposite on adjacent it's just rude
through yet okay excellent now I went
around how to look at how you're going
with these graphs can I say as well you
remember when I showed you that first
sheet on the first day last week I said
okay here's the youtube 53 course here's
the tune of course and then I drew all
these leaks right graphy is this really
really critical skill which if you don't
feel very confident with at the moment
then covered ask for help that's why I'm
here okay but you must ask for help if
you don't feel confident you cannot
leave this skill behind and be a little
bit like you know my son he's learning
to read okay and they learn sight words
like cat and dog right they learn that
kind of at the same time they learn
letters ok so like individual letters
which make up words now he can do that
for a little while and not know what the
letters in a word are but still
recognize the word but he can't do that
forever right he's got two pretty
quickly get this skill I know all my
alphabet and I don't have to think about
him anymore otherwise he's never get a
progress he's never is only going to
know how to read words that he's
memorized right and it's a similar thing
with graphs right these are kind of like
your building blocks your alphabet so
you really gotta master them y equals x
squared I think most people recognize
that one should look like that should
have a nice smooth curve and it should
pass through the origin by at the middle
of the day now this one this one's a
little bit sneaky a lot of people have
seen oh there's a minus sign I know what
it means when there's a minus sign in
front of a parabola it means that
there's a concave down it's a frowny
face a sad one right however however
it's not have a look right this guy here
it so i can expand this this is just you
know brackets and i can square it out
right so 2 minus x squared is short for
this right 2 minus X 2 minus X do you
agree with that ok so let's just extend
straight right
two times two is four two x minus x is
minus 2x okay so i've done the first one
then i go minus x times 2 which is minus
2x and then this last term watch out
there's two negatives and when you
multiply them together they cancel right
so in fact what you get here is a plus x
squared it's also just like this guy
it's um it's concave up okay that's the
direction it's facing I'll just rewrite
this so it's a little bit later that's
what you're used to seeing okay so watch
out there there was a bit of a trap now
therefore why does it look like when I
have a look at the root right x equals 2
is going to be what I'm going to get
instead of x equals 0 in there so this
is the shape i'm going to have okay you
can quickly test out if you like if you
substitute in if you put in the value of
x equals 2 here you'll get 2 minus 2
which is just 0 right and that's why I'm
right there on the axis okay for bonus
points what that point there the
y-intercept it's for and you can read it
off straight away once I've expanded it
there is right there okay because the
way you get the wider percept is how do
you find the y-intercept of a function
like when you just if it's something
really framed and not something nice at
me like this how do you go about finding
the winder sir you let the remember you
let X X you let them be 0 because all
the y axis all of these points here x is
0 right but when x equals 0 these guys
just disappear x squared disappears 0
squared 4 times 0 I don't care anything
times 0 still 0 disappears and you just
get left with that guy before ok so
there's your graph